[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء تعهدت باكستان
بالدفاع عن السعوديه في حال تعرض امنها
ووحدتها للخطر وشجب رئيس الوزراء نواز
شريف خلال لقائه العائل السعودي في الرياض
شجب اطاحه الحوثييين بالرئيس اليمني
المنتخب واعتبر شريف ان المساس بامن
السعوديه خط احمر نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في محورين ما الذي يمكن ان تضيفه
باكستان للتحالف في حربه على الحوثيين
والرئيس
المخلوع وما اثر ذلك على مستقبل العلاقات
الخليجيه
[موسيقى]
الباكستانيه اذا اعتبر رئيس الوز الزراء
الباكستاني نواز شريف المساسه بامن
السعوديه خطا احمر وتعهد مجددا بالدفاع
عنها في حال تعرض امنها ووحدتها للخطر وقد
شجب شريف اطاحه الحوثيين بالرئيس اليمني
المنتخب وحكومته وراى ان مسؤوليه اعاده
الشرعيه لليمن مسؤوليه تقع على عاتق
المجتمع الدولي
باسره الموقف الباكستاني المعلن في الرياض
لم يكن
متماهياً اسلام اباد قبل نحو اسبوعين
والذي قرر بالاجماع الزام الحكومه بالوقوف
على الحياد في الحرب بين التحالف
والحوثيين التقرير التالي يستعرض العلاقات
بين باكستان ودول
الخليج رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني نواز شريف
في الرياض بعد موقف الحياد الصادر عن
البرلمان بشان عاصفه الحزم وطلب المملكه
مشاركه باكستان في التحالف ز زاره ليست
عاديه لبحث علاقات ثنائيه لطالما كانت
مميزه ومتينه ذكر نواز شريف القاده
السعوديين بدعم اسلام باد للرياض وبان امن
المملكه خط احمر تراهن باكستان على عمق
العلاقات التاريخيه لتجاوز الحرج وخيبه
الامل الذين تسبب فيهما البرلمان منذ
العاشر من ابريل الجاري فبعد تصريحات تحدث
فيها عن استعداد بلاده الانضمام الى تحالف
عاصفه الحزم فضل شريف اللجوء الى البر
لحسم الموضوع وكان جواب البرلمان الحياد
والتاكيد على ان اي تهديد لسياده ووحده
اراضي السعوديه سيثير ردا قويا من باكستان
الحياد وصف من قبل دول خليجيه بانه تراجع
وخضوع للضغط الايراني فقبل جلسه البرلمان
زار وزير الخارجيه جواد ظريف اسلام اباد
وكلام الشريف عقب محادثاته مع المسؤول
الايراني عن الحل السلمي للازمه اليمنيه
كان بدايه التغيير في موقفه السابق بغض
النظر عن المبررات المرتبطه بالمشاكل على
الحدود مع افغانستان والهند ارادت باكستان
ان تحافظ على علاقاتها المميزه مع ايران
تاريخيا العلاقات الخليجيه الباكستانيه
وتحديدا مع السعوديه اقدم واعمق فقد ساهمت
باكستان في تاسيس سلاح الجو السعودي
والتعاون الامني بين البلدين وثق جدا
وشاركت في تحالفات سابقه مع الدول
الخليجيه عش رئيس الوزراء الحالي هو
وعائلته ع سنوات في المملكه بعد انقلاب
برويز مشرف عليه في عام 2014 قدمت الرياض
منحه قيمتها مليار ونصف مليون دولار
لمساعده الاقتصاد الباكستاني الذي يعتمد
بشكل كبير على النفط السعودي والاماراتي
امتلاك اسلام اباد للسلاح النووي عامل قوه
بالنسبه لحلفائها الخليجيين لذلك عملت
طهران خلال السنوات الاخيره على تعزيز
علاقاتها مع باكستان امتد النفوذ الايراني
اقتصاديا بل وحتى سياسيا في بلد ثلث جيشه
من المذهب عينه لعل الارتباك الاخير
للحكومه الباكستانيه مؤشر على ان ما يريده
نواز شريف ليس بالضروره ما تريده باقي
الاحزاب السياسيه والشخصيات النافذه في
البلد عوده باكستان الى الحاضنه الخليجيه
لن ترحب بها اطراف داخليه وخارجيه قد لا
تلتزم
الحياه لمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا ينضم الينا
من اسلام اباد عبد الكريم شاه مدير مركز
اسلام اباد للدراسات اس
ومن الرياض الدكتور ابراهيم النحاس استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الملك سعود ومن
الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشاجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت وابدا مع
عبد الكريم شاه سيد عبد الكريم بعد قرار
البرلمان الباكستاني الوقوف على الحياد في
الازمه اليمنيه ماذا جاء ليقدمه نواز شريف
في
الرياض نواز شريف علاقاته الشخصيه وثيقه
جدا بدول الخليج وهكذا حال الجيش
الباكستاني منذ
الستينيات وان التعاون بين الجيش
الباكستاني
والقوات المسلحه في دول الخليج تعاون وثيق
جدا وتم تدريب عدد كبير من منسوبي القوات
البحريه والجويه في دول الخليج في معاهد
متخصصه في باكستان منذ سته عقود مضت وفعلا
كانت الامال معلقه على مشاركه باكستان كون
جيشه جيش عريق جدا
واحترافي ويعتبر من اقوى الجيوش في العالم
كونه خاد حربين دوسين مع دوله جاره الهند
التي موقف جاء الموقف الذي لم يكن
متوقع جا جاء الموقف الذي لم يت يكون
متوقعا من البرلمان الزم الحكومه بالوقوف
على الحياد ما يحتاجه التحالف من باكستان
اليوم ماذا يستطيع ان يقدم منه نواز شريف
في
الرياض انت على صواب ان وسائل الاعلام
الباكستانيه التي تسيطر عليها اللوبي
الايراني اثرت بشكل كبير جدا على الراي
العام الداخلي ولا سيما البرلمان الذي قرر
ان تبقى باكستان على الحياه وتم
تصوير قوات التحالف ضد الحوثيين
بانه حرب
على بدخول باكستان اليها ستكون
بمثابه حرب بالوكاله بين دوله ج ايران و
سيد عبد الكريم اليس في الموضوع اليس في
هذا الكلام تبسيط للامر انه القصه انه
وسائل الاعلام هي التي اثرت على البرلمان
علما ان الكثير من المراقبين
والمحللين راوا بان الحكومه هي من تعمدت
احاله الموضوع الى البرلمان لانها تعرف
موقفه مسبقا وبالتالي كان بامكانها اتخاذ
قرار لوحدها لكنها تريد ان تسحب المسؤوليه
عنها فحالتها الى
البرلمان
ليس ليس الامر هكذا الحكومه منذ البدايه
كانت التزمت لدول الخليج بانها ستقف الى
جانبها وهكذا كان الحال للجيش الباكستاني
الا ان فعلا قرار البرلمان جاء ليحو دون
تحقيق تلك الرغبه ومع
ذلك استطاعت الحكومه بان تقنع
البرلمانيين بان ترسل باكستان على الاقل
بعد على الاقل بعدض السفن
الحربيه تطبيقا لقرار الامم المتحده بعدم
السماح للحوثيين بتلقي السلاح من الخارج ا
طيب من الرياض الدكتور ابراهيم النحاس هل
هذا ما كان يريده التحالف ما تريده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من باكستان مج
رد بعض السفن الحربيه تطبيقا لقرار مجلس
الامن لمنع وصول امدادات عسكريه للحوثيين
وقوات الرئيس
المخلوع شكرا استاذ حسن على الاستضافه
الكريمه لا ليس هو هذا المطلوب من الدوله
الباكستانيه كنا نامل كدول الخليج بشكل
مباشر او كتحالف عربي من الدوله
الباكستانيه ان يكون موقفها السياسي هو
الذي يدعم التحالف ويقف مع التحالف ومن
غير شروط ومن غير ايضا حتى تردد من قبل
سواء البرلمان الباكستاني او الحكومه
الباكستانيه او حتى الجيش الباكستاني نعلم
انه العلاقات الوثيقه جدا بين دول مجلس
التعاون والمملكه بشكل مباشر وباكستان
الكل كان يتطلع لذلك الراي العام الخليجي
والسعودي بشكل مباشر صابه خيبه امل كبيره
جدا من موقف البرلمان الباكستاني بغض
النظر عن التصريحات الاعلاميه هنا وهناك
من قبل الدوله الباكستانيه بان البرلمان
الباكستاني ليس ذو علاقه وليس له اهميه
على سبيل المثال في القرار السياسي الاخير
الا انه يعبر عن راي سواء كما تفضلت
للزميل انه راي حكومه او كراي عام شعبي في
الداخل الباكستاني كنا نامل ان يكون
القرار ليس مشاركه سياس مشاركه بحريه او
مشاركه عسكريه على سبيل المثال على ارض
الواقع ولكن ان يكون قرار الدوله
الباكستانيه على ارض ال يم الان بعد بعد
ذلك ماذا يمكن ان تقدم باكستان ماذا يمكن
ان يطلب ان تطلب دول الخليج والتحالف
عموما ونوازل قد جاء الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بصحبه وزير الدفاع وقائد الجيش
ايضا معنى ذلك ان ثمه امر عسكري يبحث ما
طبيعته نعم هو الزياره على احترامنا لمثل
من ياتي لمثل هذه الزيارات سواء كراي عام
خليجي الاحترام والتقدير طبيعا لكل الزوار
الا انه دائما عندما تاتي ما بعد اتخاذ
القرار وما بعد ايضا نجاح العمليه وما بعد
انتهاء العمليه لن يكون الاثر النفسي
والاثر السياسي كما هو قبل اتخاذ مثل هذه
القرارات السياسيه او النجاح فيها او
اعلان النجاح ايضا الا انه نبقى في
العلاقات الدوليه نتحدث عن مجاملات سياسيه
هنا وهناك سوف يكون القرار الباكستاني على
سبيل المثال سوف ندعم وسوف نعمل وسوف نقدم
الا انه لن يكون ذا تاثير نفسي كما كان في
مراحل ماضيه وان نتوقع انه حتى صانع
القرار السياسي السعودي او الخليجي سوف
يكون مترددا في مصداقيه مثل هذا القول
عندما ياتي من قبل الدوله الباكستانيه
وهذا نقوله بكل اسف نعلم انه الموقف
الباكستاني كان ياخذ وسبب الرئيسي والغير
معلن من قبل الدوله الباكستانيه على عدم
وقوفهم مع المملكه هو لومهم المملكه
باقامه علاقات مع الدوله الهنديه والزياره
التي قام بها خادم الحرمين الملك الراحل
عبد الله بن عبد العزيز للدوله الهنديه
وتوقيع بعدد من الاتفاقيات كان الباكستاني
يقول يفترض ان تسالنا المملكه قبل ان تذهب
الى الدوله الهنديه وهذا الحقيقه غير
منطقي وغير ذا جدوه لانه نعلم ان المملكه
علاقاتها استراتيجيه مع باكستان الهند
تبقى علاقات مصلحيه وايضا
اتضحت دكتور عبد اللهي يعني استنادا الى
ما سمعناه الان من الكتور ابراهيم النحاس
واضح بان هناك تاثر سلبي في النظره
الخليجيه الى موقع اسلام اباد وموقف
باكستان حيال القضايا الملحه التي تعنى
بالخليج وامن الخليج بشكل
خاص
دكتور عبد
الله مادري السؤال السؤال الي انا نعم نعم
اسالك ان كان دول الخليج نظرتها تاثرت
سلبا
بالموقف الباكستاني وهذا ربما نفهمه من
كلام دكتور ابراهيم واضح فهمت السؤال يعني
في البدايه خليني اوضح نقطتين مهمتين
النقطه الاولى بان هناك خيبه امل واضحه في
دول الخليج والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالتردد الباكستاني كان هناك تعويل ان
تكون هناك العلاقه استراتيجيه مبنيه على
علاقات وثيقه وعلاقات يعني متبادله خاصه
بان نواز شريف شخصيا هو الشخصيه
الباكستانيه الاكثر اطلاعا والاكثر صله
والاكثر علاقه بحميميه و ووثيقه علاقته مع
القيادات في السعوديه و ويعني يدين
للسعوديه بابقاء على قيد الحياه عندما كان
يعني محكوم بالاعدام بعد الانقلاب الذي
قام في عام 99 من قبال برويز مشرف
واستضافته السعوديه ك يعني في كلاجئ سياسي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه فمث
للاستغراب ان ان يعني ينقل الكره الى
المشاركه في عاصفه الحزم الى البرلمان مع
ان هو يعني حسب الدستور الباكستاني غير
ملزم
بقرار البرلمان الباكستاني الذي صوت
بالاجماع بالامتناع او بالحياد وهذا
يذكرني بما قام به الرئيس اوباما في اغسطس
2013 عندما كان بيملك القدره على ضرب
القدرات العسكريه لبشار الاسد في سوريا
بعد استخدام الكيماوي في غطي دمشق بان
يرسل ال طلب المشاركه او قيام بعمليات
عسكريه ضد نظام الاسد الى الكونجرس
الامريكي الذي كان مترددا والذي فيما بعد
رفض وسحب الرئيس اوباما الطلب يعني الموقف
الباكستاني بالفعل يثير الكثير من علامات
الاستفهام خضع للضغوط على ما يبدو من
ايران واذكر اني عشيه عمليه عاصفه الحزم
كان نواز شريف شخصيا في زياره لل المملكه
وزارها امس ويمكن يقدم الاعتذار او
توضيحات لماذا لم يشارك انا في اعتقادي في
ثلاث اسباب لم يشارك السبب الاول هو ان
هناك يعني ضغوط من ايران واضحه جدا عبر
تزويد باكستان بالغاز السبب الثاني ما
تقول القياده العسكريه بان هناك يعني هم
مشتبك الان في عمليات عسكريه ضد القاعده
وضد طالبان باكستان وضد يعني الداخل
الباكستاني والنقطه الثالثه ان 15 الى 20%
من الشعب الباكستاني من الطائفه الشيعيه
ولا يريد ان يفاقم الاوضاع داخل باكستان
وان ي هذا صراع سني شيعي في المنطقه وان
هناك اطفاف لدول سنيه مقابل اصطفاف ضد
الحوثيين
والداعمين هذه الاسباب اعتقا التي رجحت
كفه
انه العص من الوسط جاء الى الرياض فقط من
اجل ان يعتذر يعني كانه جاء الى الرياض من
اجل ان نعتذر ام
اي يلحق الامر بخطوات عملان بعد ان وصلت
عاصفه الحزم الى النتائج التي وصلت اليها
الا يمكن ان يكون لهذه الزياره مفاعيل
عمليه على
الارض يعني طبعا الحين عاصفه الحزم يعني
حسب كل البيانات انتهت نحن نتكلم عن الان
مبادره الامل او يعني ما تقوم به الان
القوات المسلحه هي قوات خليجيه واعاده
الامل يعني لا يوجد فيه دور مشاركه
باستثناء القصف بالطيران عندما تدعي
الحاجه فما هو الدور الباكستاني هناك
مبالغه من البدايه بالدور الباكستاني ودور
من يريد ان يرسل قواته للمشاركه في حرب
بريه من قال منذ البدايه ان كان هناك حرب
بريه اصلا يعني يعني هناك في مبالغه انه
لماذا اوقفت كما يروج الاعلام المناوئ
لعاصفه الحزم بان سبب
عدم او او سبب ايقاف عاصفه الحزم ويعني ال
وقفها بشكل مفاجئ هو لعدم مشاركه باكستان
وارسالها قوات بريه الرد على هذه على على
هذه يعني النقاط هي انه من قال بان من
البدايه كان هناك في حرب بريه وخاصه ان
الحرب البريه ستكون معقده جدا وصعبه يمكن
نقطه اخيره بالنسبه للباكستاني تذكرون
يعني المعاناه التي عناها الجيش المصري في
الستينيات في في في في اليمن على ايام عبد
الناصر ولا يريدون ايضا ان يخوضوا حرب في
مستنقع جديد لهم في اليمن فهذه نقطه ايضا
مهمه ومنذ البدايه ما اعتقد ان المخططين
العسكريين في الخطه او المرحله الثانيه
كانت قوات بريه ولهذا السبب يعني لم نرى
ان هناك حتى في تفكير لقوات لمشاركه بقوات
بريه فاعتقد زياره نواز شريف امس الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبوف رفيع جدا
المستوى وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان ووزير
الخارجيه ورئيس الوزراء ومستشاره الشخصي
كان عباره عن يعني محاوله لايصال رساله
بان لا تزال باكستان تدعم المملكه حليف
استراتيجي رئيسي ولكن القرار اتى من
البرلمان لا املك الكثير من طبعا هذا
الكلام غير صحيح رس الزملك القدره بان لا
يستمع للبرلمان و ويرسل قوات اذا اراد ذلك
هذه العلاقات سوف نناقشها مشاهدينا بعد
الفاصل في ضوء ما يجري في اليمن ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش العلاقات الخليجيه الباكستانيه
في ضوء ما يجري في اليمن واعود الى ضيفي
من اسلام اباد عبد الكريم شاه سيد عبد
الكريم هل اسلام اباد معنيه وحريصه فعليا
على اعاده العلاقات الخليجيه الباكستانيه
السعوديه الباكستانيه الى ما قبل اكثر من
ع سنوات
خلت باكستان فعلا حريصه جدا على ان تحافظ
على هذه العلاقات العميقه الوديه بينها
وبين دول الخليج بالنسبه لما ذكر ان دعم
باكستان السياسي لعاصفه الحزم هذا كان
موجود من اول يوم نواز شريف حتى خلال
زيارته للرياض الان التقى
ب رئيس اليمن عبد ربو منصور هادي
و اكد له ان باكستان
تعتبره رئيسا شرعيا
ل اليمن وان باكستان تدعم
الشرعيه لدوله اليمن انما فعلا
هناك اشياء بقيت غامض منذ اول وهد
وهي ان الاخوه قالوا ان العمليه البريه لم
تكن في ذهن المخططين اساسا ليس لم يكن هذا
الموضوع بل كانت العمليه البريه فعلا ضمن
المخطط وباكستان شعرت بان توقيت عاصمه
الحزم للاسف الشديد جاء في وقت كان الجيش
الباكستاني متواجد على حدود الشرقيه امام
الهند وحدودها الغربيه امام افغانستان
وايضا منشغله في عمليات ضد طالبان باكستان
في وزيرستان وايضا في خيبر
بون واضافه الى ذش سيد عبد الكريم اريد ان
اسالك سؤال مباشر يعني كما هو معروف في
المنطقه الان هناك محوران محور ايراني
ومحور عربي تجلى هذا المحور العربي
بالتحالف ضد الحوثيين وقوات الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح طبعا هذا
المحور يواجه المحور الايراني في اكثر من
منطقه هل الان اسلام اباد مستعده لان
تنحاز الى
المحور
العربي كرد جميل اذا صح التعبير على ما
قدمته لها دول الخليج والدول العربيه في
اكثر من مرحله من
عمرها
هذا المحور له جانبان هناك معارضه داخل
باكستان ان تدخل باكستان لمحور تحالف سني
ضد الشيعي لان باكستان لا تستطيع ان تفتح
لها جبهه ثالثه على حدودها مع ايران لان
ايران هي حدودها المشتركه كدوله ثالثه
اضافه الى افغانستان
والهند والصين فلا تستطيع ان تفتح هذه
الجبهه الثالثه بان تصبح حدودها مع دوله
ايران متوتره
ومشتعل لان فعلا باكستان تعتبرها عمقها
الاستراتيجي تتذكرون ان طائرات
باكستانيه في حربها مع الهند في عام
65 كانت كانت تطير
من النقطه اتضحت دكتور ابراهيم النحاس
دكتور
ابراهيم استنادا او انطلاقا مما سمعته
الان بكل صراحه ووضوح هل تعتقد بان دول
الخليج
اي تعول على اعاده العلاقات تحديدا
السعوديه الان اتحدث معك تعول على اعاده
العلاقات الى سابق عهدها مع باكستان الى
ما قبل عشر سنوات خصوصا في المجال العسكري
وانت سمعت الى محاذير التي تتحدث بها
باكستان نعم صانع القرار السعودي او حتى
العربي الان وان كان يملك القرار السياسي
الكامل الا انه ايضا هناك راي عام غالب
وضاغط جدا مهما كان قوه صانع القرار ونعلم
انه الراي العام الان اصبح في دول مجلس
التعاون وفي المملكه بشكل خاص ولعله ايضا
حتى في الدول العربيه الاخرى اصبح يشك في
المواقف الباكستانيه بشكل مباشر ولعله
ايضا ما اتى على لسان الزميل من اسلام
اباد يعطينا مؤشر بانه اصبح حتى
الباكستانيون يتحدثوا بلغه او بلسان
الايرانيون واللغه التي اتت قبل قليل على
سبيل المثال محور شيعي سني هذه لغه
ايرانيه وليست لغه باكستانيه باي حال من
الاحوال ويبدو انه الراي العام اصبح او
الى حد ما حتى المتحدثون الباكستان تحدثوا
بلغه ايرانيه لم يكن للمملكه او لدول مجلس
التعاون في اي يوم من الايام الفكره
الطائفيه او المذهبيه كانن او شيعه دكتور
ابراهيم مصير هذا الاستثمار
في الجيش الباكستاني في الجانب العسكري
وايضا ماذا عن المستقبل والاستثمار او ما
حكي عن استثمار سعودي في النووي
الباكستاني يعني هذه امور كبيره ما هو
مصيرها
صحيح اتوقع انه لن يكون هناك مستقبل يبشر
بالخير حقيقه تجاه مثل هذه المواقف وهذا
نقوله بكل اسف لن يكن هناك ايضا الاستثمار
السابق سوف يكون ذو جدوى بالنسبه لدول
مجلس التعاون ولعلها تعد من من
الاستثمارات الغير مربحه لدول مجلس
التعاون او لدول العربيه ونقول ذلك فعلا
بكل اسف لانه المنحى الباكستاني في
السنوات الاخيره لعله في الخمس سنوات
الاخيره يصب في الاتجاهات الايرانيه ولا
يصب في الاتجاهات للاسف الخليجيه وهذا
عودا على بدء في عام 90 في في الاستثمار
في القوات العراقيه والتي اتت
عاكسه بالاتجاه على الول العربيه واحتلال
الدوله الكويتيه فبالتالي لعل يكون في
ام دكتور عبد الله الشايجي هل
اي لم يعد في الامكان اقله في المستقبل
المنظور الاعتماد على باكستان او عوده اي
العلاقات الخليجيه الباكستانيه الى
ازدهارها
السابق لا انا في اعتقادي العلاقه
استراتيجيه ستبقى يعني هذه طبعا يعني
ستكون انعطاف ولكن هناك علاقه استراتيجيه
اكدها البرلمان حتى الباكستاني واكدها
الرئيس الباكستاني ان هناك دعم للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقوف مع المملكه وايضا
اذا ما تعرضت لتهديد من ايران او من اي
طرف اخر وكذلك يعني من مبادئ ايضا العقيده
الباكستانيه الدفاع عن الحرمين الشريفين
فهذه لا يمكننا بسبب ما يعني ما يعني
الخلاف الان او امساك الباكستانيين العصى
من الوسط ولعب لعبه براغماتيه لعدم لعدم
اقضاب ايران ولعدم الدخول في بين محوري
السني والشيعي مع ان نحن لا نريد ان تكون
هذه هي هذا هو التوصيف ولكن الباكستانيين
لعبوا لعبه براغماتيه واعتقد نواز شريف
اتى وشرح هذا الموقف للقياده في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الموقف الباكستاني مخيب
للامال في هذا المنعطف والسؤال الكبير
الذي يطرح الان اذا كان هذا هو الوضع في
هذه عندما تكون نحن في حاله حرب والحليف
الرئيسي لباكستان في العالم العربي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في حاله حرب
واضحه وتطلب مساعده وباكستان تتردد وتمسك
العصى من الوسط رئيس الوزراء يوصل الطلب
الى البرلمان بينما هو كان مستطاع ان يتخذ
القرار دون العوده للبرلمان فماذا لو كان
هناك في حاجه اعم واشمل خاصه الب
النو للاصلاح حدثتنا من الكويت واشكر من
الرياض ابراهيم النحاس استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الملك سعود ومن اسلام اباد عبد
الكريم شاه مدير مركز اسلام اباد للدراسات
السياسيه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء